[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] في عام 2010 ، كنا نتطلع إلى
توسيع سعة المبنى رقم 1 ، قررنا
أن هيكل مواقف السيارات في الهواء الطلق
يمكن أن يصبح
مجمعًا متكاملًا جديدًا بالإضافة إلى خلق
جاذبية حقيقية في حد ذاته ، حيث كان
يقدم للركاب المقيمين المحليين أكثر
خيارات
[موسيقى]
سنغافورة مكان صغير ، وبالتالي
لدينا الكثير من السكان المحليين الذين
يأتون إلى المطار لقضاء
عطلات نهاية الأسبوع حيث يأتي الناس هنا
لدراسة الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى هنا في المواعيد ،
وهناك بالفعل أشخاص يسألوننا هل
يمكنني تنظيم  حفل زفاف ، شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذلك عندما تدخل في الأداة ، فلنقتل
التجربة حتى تحصل على حديقة فقط ،
ستحصل على تجربة غامرة تمامًا لنا ،
حيث يمكنك  حقًا يتجول
ويغمر في الطبيعة
[تصفيق]